so you talk about collaboration what if
a collaboration is not working what if
it is unbalanced what is the best way
for all of the collaborators to handle
that you mean like if you have a film
set and you have one person that's
disruptive or not so much I mean just
like you know we're all in this to
collaborate because we're all now these
multi - it's alright with the advent of
crowdfunding and DSLR cameras and stuff
so we can all kind of do this project on
our own but we need the help of others
so you're in a collaboration and the
collaboration is unbalanced it's not
necessarily on the film set
everybody has their role yeah and how
does someone handle that amicably Wow I
said the work well I think you know I
would imagine that in that particular
situation there's gonna be somebody
that's gonna be in charge and I think
that that person needs to be able to
take the temperature of what's going on
and you know I think it speaks to what I
said earlier about the fact that there's
more competition than ever so if there
is somebody
everybody's expendable I mean that's the
bottom line
everybody's expendable I mean I've seen
people who fired off for shoots three
quarters of the way through it may be a
little tough away to actors but I've
seen you know really quality dps get
knocked off you know 75 percent of the
way through it because he's being a
disruptive force so he thinks that you
know he wants to override the director
or whatever it's it's tougher than ever
it's it's funny there's more competition
than ever right now because the barrier
of entry to making a film and and you
know the the amount the proliferation of
places where you could distribute a film
the battery of entries gone down the
distribution channels have gone up that
means more people rushing into the arena
you know saying I can do this I can do
this I can do this okay
that's good and bad the good the bad is
there's so much noise okay but the the
good is that you could rise above that
noise very very easy okay
AFET being professional putting your
best foot forward being a true
collaborator on and off the set okay
assisting people showing you best face
online you know like Ivy said earlier
filling out your profile online if
you're going to do that kind of thing
okay every one of these things gives you
another percentage of Vantage you know
it could be five percent 10 percent 15
percent over what other people aren't
doing you know so to me you know if
you're gonna have somebody that is gonna
be a disruptive force or somebody that
is throwing off the balance of things
you know you I I think you try to
address it and you give somebody the
benefit of the doubt and see if there's
some sort of underlying circumstance
that's causing that person to be off
kilter but if it ends up just being a
personality dispute of some sort and the
pool is filled with people that could
replace that person how do you sever it
well I think you gotta be honest I mean
I think everything comes down to honesty
in this life I think you just have to be
honest with the person and you know say
it's not working I mean I just think
that like we said earlier when we were
talking about screenwriting if you're
not getting honesty then you're getting
you know all you're doing is setting a
person back you know if you're not if
you're just telling people good things
and you're not being honest how does
that person grow how do you grow so I
think it's I think everything in life
comes down to honesty and so going
separate ways and probably just not
speaking your truth to other people
about it because then that might poison
it for another person you know there's a
lot of talk in this town and sometimes
people take sides yeah well I think well
when it comes to Hollywood I think
you're gonna need to be the ultimate
diplomat I mean I just think it's late
as nobody wants to burn a bridge in this
town because you know it's been said a
million times before the person that's
in the mailroom today could be running
the studio tomorrow and it's not
unprecedented I just think that if you
handle yourself in a professional manner
and you handle yourself in a
collaborative manner and you know that
second part is difficult for some people
because we do a lot of work in isolation
you know writers filmmakers even actors
running lines with learning they're
learning they're
lines but if you embrace the true
collaborative spirit you're not going to
get yourself in trouble in this business
you're not gonna find yourself in those
situations very often or you shouldn't
and if you do consistently find yourself
in those positions then I think you need
to look in the mirror what about if one
for seems to be overriding the force too
much and one personality is too strong
how do you know the balance is right
well I think everybody's opinion matters
I think healthy debate you know it's
always great if somebody is unwilling to
yield their position at a certain point
I think that that's just another thing
that needs to be addressed I mean I just
think that again you know that we this
is a collaborative business and we all
you know great films even great theater
you know it happens because everybody
pulls in the same direction and you know
it's very very rare that something comes
together that's great where there's been
controversy or conflict throughout so if
the person that's being headstrong can't
yield then like I said pull somebody
else out of the pool
speaking of Coppola or does he say
everything you build with great passion
and bites chaos that's true too
but I think I think it invites chaos
within more than I think it's internal
chaos I think you know I mean Coppola I
love Coppola
you know and he talks a ton about the
the internal challenge of the artist and
the creator and I think that that's more
of what he's talking about I think that
we create a lot of chaos for ourselves
and I think we create a lot of chaos for
ourselves
you know doubt fear I mean it's
prevalent always I don't care who you
are
there's always you know anxiety but you
know you deal with it the best you can
you don't put it out onto somebody else
you don't you know transfer it you know
you